the u.s secretary of state meets
ukraine's president vladimir zelinski in
kiev where anthony blinken renewed calls
for russia to choose diplomacy over
confrontation today
there are
some 100 000 russian soldiers
near ukraine's borders uh and
in that sense the threat to ukraine is
unprecedented so the president asked me
to underscore once again
our commitment uh to ukraine's
territorial integrity to its sovereignty
uh to its independence
the hastily arranged visit comes as
washington confirms another 200 million
dollars in military aid for kiev that's
angered moscow it says that's a threat
to its security
analysts in ukraine say the aid may
change president vladimir putin's
calculations but they're not hopeful
declaring political support from the
site of united states and providing
such military
military supplies can deter russian
aggression of course russia will
emphasize that
providing these military weapons is
a red line for them uh but it is the
only way
to
for ukraine to defend itself now
tensions between nato and moscow over
ukraine have been growing for months
putin is demanding that the americans
pledge never to let ukraine join nato or
expand the military alliance eastward a
demand the u.s refuses to accept
russia's leader also says the u.s
shouldn't be concerned about joint
military exercises with belarusian
forces due to start next month
western countries have accused the
kremlin of preparing a pretext for an
assault on ukraine but some analysts say
there's still room for a diplomatic
solution to this crisis
myself
i find it unlikely that russia would
attack ukraine
in this manner that people expect with
huge land force that would inevitably
result in many casualties i do not think
that russian society and russian
political system could take that
psychological blow
easily
blinking is due to whole talks with
russia's foreign minister sergey lavrov
in geneva on friday as world powers try
to defuse the crisis
but the u.s and its allies say they are
ready to respond with severe
consequences if russia attacks ukraine
victoria gatenbee al jazeera